alexa ray corriea here with a news  update a multiplayer free to play halo  is coming to pc available only in Russia  no fair Microsoft has confirmed that  halo online will be coming this spring  running on a highly modified halo 3  engine there is no single player  campaign mode although it isn't  completely devoid of a plot microsoft  statement says that halo a line set on a  secret UNSC space installation called  anvil where spartan for soldiers trained  together in war exercises to sharpen  their battle skills and test  experimental technology microsoft  confirmed that it has no plans to bring  halo online to xbox one and said it has  no current plans to release it in North  America or Europe although they haven't  ruled out the possibility the game is  being developed by saber interactive  which helps develop the master chief  collection did this spell the end for  csgo no it totally doesn't for more news  head to gamespot com / news  you